gwynda's third Paradox in order for you
to beat someone in a debate your
opponent needs to realize they've lost
therefore it's easier to win an argument
against a genius than an idiot
this is the reason I stopped debating
yeah
you know I I well it's one of the
reasons anyway I I used to debate people
all the time on social media you know I
used to I used to think it was something
worth doing I just thought you know that
if I could convince people but I
realized um after a while that really a
debate is not it's not it's not really a
battle of intellect it's not a match of
wits
uh it's really just
uh it's a more of a battle of ego
than internet because people want to win
they don't want to understand and they
approach their they approach debates
uh well basically there's a rationalist
thinker called Julia galef who had this
great book called
um Scout mindset she came on she
basically made the yeah yeah great yeah
yeah in fact I think I saw that one yeah
and um yeah she yeah she made the case
that basically when people
um when they enter debates they tend to
approach with the soldier mindset which
is that they just want to win they just
want to conquer the enemy they have no
real other goal but they should really
approach with a scout mindset which is
to seek as much information as possible
uh to objective information do what
Scout does rather than what soldier does
but the problem is that most people are
sold they approach with the soldier
mindset and
when you approach with a soldier mindset
and you're not very bright
what will happen is you'll often just
keep going because your ego is just
driving you you know further and further
and you you won't see that you're you've
actually lost in the debate because your
ego is just there and you just you're
trying to do everything you can you're
moving the goal posts you know as much
as you can to try to win at all costs I
think with smart people this is not say
that smart people don't approach and
Solomon said they also can be extremely
um egotistical and they can be arrogant
like that but they often are more likely
to realize when they've screwed up when
they've contradicted themselves or when
they've uh you know they said something
that's just factually Incorrect and it's
harder for them to come back
from that because they realize they've
screwed up you know so they're like oh
okay and they can't just pretend they
can't just you know yeah some of them
will but
talks about this he says that um once
you've become convinced of something
even if you claim the opposite you can
no longer unconvince yourself of it if I
convince you that it's two equals four
and you then see it you can tell me no
no it's three I know it's three but on
the inside you you can't become an up
until a point at which somebody
convinces you of something else you
can't be unconvinced of something which
you are convinced of but as you've
spoken about in your most recent sub
stack article that everybody needs to go
and read smart people plus ideology is a
terrifying a terrifying cocktail because
that can use their Ingenuity to engineer
a more easily a more uh fortified
defense around their irrational beliefs
or around just beliefs that they haven't
assessed so there's a another thing that
relates to this so gwynda's third
Paradox about needing to ensure that
your opponent has to work out that
they've lost this is from Scott
Alexander and years ago this is from his
old stuff if you're interested in being
on the right side of disputes you will
refute your opponent's arguments but if
you're interested in producing truth you
will fix your opponent's Arguments for
them to win you must fight not only the
creature you encounter you must fight
the most horrible thing that be king
that can be constructed from its corpse
it's a very good way of putting it yeah
um there's a concept called rogerian
rhetoric which is how I try to approach
uh any kind of discussion which is
instead of trying to convince that
person that they're wrong what I try to
do is I try to understand that person's
belief system as as well as I can
so I don't necessarily deny or defy
anything that they say
I just listen and then I ask them
questions to work out how they came to
that conclusion and then I leave the
discussion not having convinced them but
having a better understanding of why
they believe what they believe
and I think that's far more important
you know because that helps me to better
understand positions that I disagree
with then I will formally maybe I will
attack their beliefs in a piece of
writing you know where I can really
think it through and I don't have
somebody you know moving the goal posts
or anything like that but I'll do that
formally in like an essay I won't do it
in a discussion I found that trying to
change somebody's beliefs in a debate is
almost pointless it's like kind of
change their mind through a rap battle
you know
it works for it worked for Eminem and
Eight Mile but yeah I I am I'm totally
on board with that and someone asked in
a q a a couple of weeks ago about how I
remain at least partially impartial uh
when it comes to speaking to people and
for me the question asking I I called it
the Socratic method but you've just
called it what was that one
rogerian rhetoric it's different from
the Socratic method because the Socratic
method is an attempt to win an argument
it's basically attempt to ask questions
until you lead somebody into
contradicting themselves or into saying
something that's not true whereas
rogerio rhetoric dispenses with that
completely
rhetoric is purely about um
trying to understand the other person's
position from a a neutral objective
point of view so trying to understand
what experiences in their life LED them
to the beliefs that they have have
happened with them now no matter how
wrong those beliefs are you know so if
somebody
um believes that the world is flat
instead of trying to refute that instead
of saying oh you know if you use your
binoculars and you you peer out over the
horizon you'll see that the sales of
ships appear before their prowls you
could say something like that to refute
them or what you could do is ask them so
how did you come to this belief system
and what is the evidence that convinced
you and then once you've asked these
questions you get a better understanding
of why they believed what they believe
why they were persuaded by that and that
in itself is valuable because now you
understand why people believe it which
is probably more valuable to you than
understand just refuting them and
changing their beliefs do you get what
I'm saying so it's a different it's a
different value system it's basically
more about understanding I actually
think that that is much closer to
the position that I take as well because
my goal is very rarely to ask people
questions that make them look stupid up
until the point at which they re recant
all of the opinions that they've got uh
it's much closer to that how do you
spell that first thing
so it's o r v e g e r i a n so Roger i a
n on the end Roger yeah yeah sorry okay
cool so this relates to something that I
wrote about a couple of weeks ago which
is what I've called the soft signal of
Effectiveness triggering a tribal
response is antithetical to having an
effective behavior and belief-changing
message it's nowhere near as sexy to
caveat heavily but when it comes to
important subjects the most compelling
arguments are sometimes the gentler ones
if you care about changing Behavior
you'll dial back the aggression of your
argument
yeah I think I think I tweeted something
once which was along the lines of um if
you want to convince people show them
that you can be convinced
and I think that works very well in in
life because if you if you show people
that you're open to their arguments and
that you know you're you're willing to
hear what they have to say people are
far more likely to reciprocate because
they see they see you as more of an
open-minded person and they say okay
this person gave me a chance so I'll
give him a chance you know it's like
um if you if you go into and I would
straight away trying to win and you
immediately deny what they're saying and
you say that this is wrong this is
instead of actually listening to your
arguments they judge your character they
essentially use wickenstein's ruler in a
way
um they they basically form a
personality profile of you and they say
this person is very uh close-minded you
know he's not even listening to he's
just refuted he's trying to refute what
I'm saying he's attacking me and then
they they go into war mode you know they
start red alert and then they basically
want to you know debate you so you you
set yourself up to fail the moment you
try to immediately refute what
somebody's saying I think it's much
better just to sort of um just to listen
to them and
again you know use this rogerian return
understand why they believe what they
believe and I mean this shouldn't you
know this shouldn't be
um something that you do just so you can
win an argument you shouldn't just
listen to them so that you can
understand their argument so that you
can beat their argument but it should
really be a goal in itself just to
understand you know that you you have a
better understanding of other people
because it's it's important to
understand why people believe what they
believe just as much as it's important
to believe the right thing
you know so
um it it it helps particularly for
people like you and me who are seeking
to understand human behavior we need to
understand why people adopt false
beliefs and that is much better achieved
by just
having a good conversation with them not
disagreeing with them just asking them
questions about their belief about their
life about why you know what kind of
evidence convinced them what kind of
evidence might convince them that
they're wrong you know and and these
kinds of things and then it makes you
more well equipped to deal with these
beliefs in the future as well that's an
added bonus what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]